hello there guys earlier today we got
new footage of the mandalorian season 2
with an announcement for the new and
final trailer
i'll play the clip for you now i've been
quested to bring this one back to its
kind
wherever i go he goes the mandalorian
new season streaming october 30th tune
into monday night football for an
exclusive low
so with this new footage we have amanda
lauren saying i've been quested to bring
this one
back to its kind so this makes me
believe that um a large part of this
season will actually be
the mandalorian searching for baby
yoda's um homeworld or his species to um
you know give him back to him
so i think they'll be pretty excited and
possibly we'll finally get a name reveal
for yoda species
or possibly it will be still kept a
mystery anyway so we have a couple new
clips with um the first one
being um tie fighters looking like it's
chasing something
and then we cut to a clip where we see
cara doon grief
kaga and a methoral which i think is
actually the same one from season one
episode one
where we saw the mandalorian actually
put him in carbonite freezing
so i guess he could be back we have to
wait and see i guess
anyway so the final new clip we see a
troop
transport crushing a scout trooper on a
speeder bike here
i think this shot could be a
continuation of the previous one
possibly grief cargo and stuff in the
troop transport
anyways that's about it for the new
footage but back to the big thing a new
special look or a new trailer
is releasing on monday night football so
this is a trailer we've all been waiting
for we all been itching to see us so
katana
will we see her in this trailer i
believe we will see her in this trailer
or possibly lucasfilm could go with a
more
spoiler-free approach which they've been
doing over these tv spots
anyway guys let me know what you think
do you think we'll see us okatano and
what do you want to see in the new
trailer with that out of the way please
subscribe
like and i'll catch you guys in the next
[Music]
video
[Music]
you